Eduardo knows all too well that being
kidnapped and then simply disappearing
as the biggest danger a few years ago
his brother disappeared as he made his
second attempt to reach the US Mossad
Rosita and Chiapas we got as far as
Chavez but the police caught me and
deported me back to Honduras around 90
members of the caravan currently making
its way north are said to have
disappeared after getting on two trucks
the reports from various organizations
have not yet been confirmed I'm probably
going to share our differing accounts of
the numbers missing some sources say 80
human rights authorities are looking
into this case Romano Astana investigan
doe it's feared that they may have been
kidnapped and handed over to organized
crime groups active in the area where
they went missing now others in the
caravan are spooked when joven lost
sight of his two friends he thought he'd
never see them again I guess I was
really worried they had disappeared and
I would never hear from them again we
got separated while I was trying to find
space on one of the vehicles I had no
idea where they had gone aid agencies
say between ten and twenty thousand
migrants have disappeared in the last
ten years that's one reason why people
are queuing to get into this tent inside
they can call their families for free to
reassure them that they are still okay
we're gambling with our lives if you
don't fall off the train you get run
over by a truck we're most afraid for
the children because of the danger the
people in the stadium divided
register according to the region they
came from that way they hope any
disappearances will be noticed it's very
dangerous
traveling between Mexico City and the US
border we need to be well organized and
able to look after each other we have to
know about each other every individual
every child organized crime is lying in
white everywhere on the journey ahead
the migrants are at risk of kidnapping
and blackmail criminals lure the
migrants with fake office of work then
they're forcibly held and subjected to
human trafficking ser a bravados de la
liberté possible Amenti attempts to dupe
the migrants even take place within
temporary accommodation in Mexico City
the president of the Mexican Federal
Human Rights Commission says migrants
are often approached by people claiming
to be officials Navi Ignacio he believes
no one had heard of the supposed
organization they offer to take people
in lorries in groups of 18 north and
over the border into the u.s. those with
the biggest concern for the people in
the caravan is to avoid falling victim
to criminals exploiting their
desperation